[Musique]
elle va mêler des bassins je n'avais
rien contre eux
rivard est court après mais ça n'a pas
été la même
mais commencent à demander si ils
prennent les quoi
du jamais vu chez ses parents d'élise
safari marc dumas n autorise pas
calmez vous calmez vous trop d'agitation
vous avez vous avez à la remise vous
avez alors si vous voulez du catch up
vous appuyez shimano pour l'habiller tu
va te changer à la pub parce que là on
pourra pas faire une émission comme ça
on a des plus grands stylistes du monde
gérait bien toi par les deschiens
c'était hier encore on dirait qu'il va
changer une roue sur quoi ils me font
j'adore l'aspirateur qui étaient là et
battu à que manu déjà parlé j'ai levé le
doigt bas mais le poids dans le cul dans
la poule 4
non mais c'est fou ce que d'habitude où
il est souvent pour rien dans l'émission
il annonce alors dans son rôle pour moi
le meilleur c'était maxime savez que
c'est quoi ce rôle c'était dur je pense
que je peux décider mais témoin
[Applaudissements]
braguette ouverte c'est arrivé à fabien
lecoeuvre un jour il ya eu d'évacuation
des locaux
les gens donnent à retrouver le monstre
du loch ness
hier le petit c'est quand même le rêve
de l'homme de volley a bien sûr la seule
chose où notre avis est que tu te barres
aussi
jours
quel type active de la tomate locales à
l'eau et l'acidité chez toi tu sais
pourquoi tu sais ce que tu peux faire
quoi les gens ne peut se faire passer
pour un enfant
bah oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors quoi
[Musique]